president Trump stunned Republicans by
embracing a democratic plan on critical
funding issues in an oval office meeting
yesterday the president came to terms
with Democratic leaders Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer not his Republican friends
to raise the debt limit and fund the
government until mid-december and the
deal left Republicans in the meeting
dumbfounded Margaret Brennan's at the
White House Margaret good morning what
happened
good morning well this short-term deal
also provides billions in hurricane
relief but it gives Democrats leverage
in an upcoming December fight over
issues like the border wall the
president here decided to buck his own
party in part because he's lost
confidence in its leaders ability to
gather votes we had a great meeting with
Chuck Schumer Nancy Pelosi and the whole
Republican leadership group President
Trump called his deal with the Democrats
and historic example of bipartisanship
we walked out and everybody was happy
but not everyone was happy in fact all
five Republicans in the room including
Treasury secretary minuchin had proposed
a longer-term deal than the Democratic
version mr. Trump startled the group
when he sided with top Democrats Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer the awkward
moment was interrupted by mr. Trump's
daughter Ivanka who suddenly walked into
the room further irritating Republican
allies the president's compromise
undercuts House Speaker Paul Ryan who
had just hours earlier dismissed that
very same proposal I think that's a
ridiculous and disgraceful that they
want to play politics with the debt
ceiling at this moment afterward a
stunned Republican Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell chose his words carefully
president can speak for himself
but his feeling was that we needed to
come together Senator Chuck Schumer a
former friend of President Trump from
his home state of New York took credit
for the rare display of bipartisanship
today was a good day in a generally very
partisan town well White House aides
argue the president wanted to build some
positive momentum that he feels he's
gained in the aftermath of Harvey and
his management of that crisis and turn
that into his push for tax reform
Gail despite that tense meeting House
Speaker Paul Ryan is still slated to
have dinner
with the president here tonight and I
know you'd like to be a fly on that walk
oh boy yeah we don't like to be a couple
of flies on that wall
thank you very much Margaret words you
never thought you'd hear the president
say we had a great meeting with Chuck
Schumer and Nancy Pelosi for the fact
that it's always unpredictable that
might have addictive yeah